we're making a weapon and one of the
cool things about this game is there's
almost unlimited combinations to the
kinds of weapons you can make so
i love to make a banana handle i love
the ripe bananas like the poster the
green bananas
got a little brown to them i call them i
call them freckles
there's freckles on that banana well
i've got freckles that's what it's
called i know
you're a banana you you're a large
banana i'm not a large banana i'm a
human being that happens to have
freckles
i know but you're but you're you're
you're you're still related to the
bananas
and not related to the banana how do you
know for banana if you if you've got
freckles like and
this banana has freckles you got
freckles
you know what's up yup squash
run away but i ain't no pump i ain't no
punk
what am i running away
it doesn't mean you're a punk sometimes
you've got you know you run
you're a punk you hear me you're a punk
you're running away from your
from your from your issues and your
problems i want people to think
i'm a coward no one thinks you're a
coward the guy brought out it was a
giant monster eight times bigger than
you
and he had a big steel ball with spikes
people expect you to run
oh my god you are unbelievable
jb how would you describe your fighting
style if you get into a fight
someone will whip your ass right unless
they are far from you
you got a jab you got long arms but if i
get in your chest
you can't do nothing if you got up in
here i'd be powerless against you
your arms are nothing what if i had this
right here jb oh what if i had that you
got me you got me yeah see
i got you two you keep you give me your
bed there's part of what you can do
nothing you can do i can't get in there
you know what i do i keep one of these
in my car here in la i walk around with
it
if i'm not feeling safe oh i'm walking
down the street getting some graham
crackers
with me i love that how about this right
here yeah yeah and then you and i
we go at it and we go like this yeah you
know what we'll be really what
what happened yours is oh what happened
yours in medieval times yeah and and go
jousting yeah i would love to challenge
you to a job listen let's high five
let's hop on
oh good there yeah good positive energy
right now i went what happened you fell
into
what did i do you walked right into uh
some sludge when you had this controller
jb
yeah death and destruction everything
moving through every level
with the speed and rapidity i've never
seen before you handed it to me
and almost immediately i walked into
some goop
and drowned you walked into some group
and drowned the group was there
i love when you say goop by the way i
was i saw a group i saw it sitting there
i saw it moving and i said you shouldn't
walk in that but by the time
i was thinking he shouldn't be walking
that he walked in it
you walked in the group i love when he
says walk into the goop
walking goop that's my favorite thing
ever
[Laughter]
i love how you you stay so low you use
your smallness as an advantage
right yup something you can't do in real
life jb because you're very tall man
you got to die right here you're going
to die pop up
i'm not playing with you really gonna
play him i'm getting this dude facebook
what's up you think i'm playing with you
look at me huh
he's dead don't step in any goop like i
did no i know how goop looks
you know how many times i stepped in
goop okay if you keep saying goop i'm
gonna lose it
i'm just gonna lose it i've stepped in
goop plenty of times
mama look who's the bag
come on man it's me
[Laughter]
oh man i love these stories you are so
into it you have such a great positive
attitude about these games
you have conan i would be making fun of
his helmet
and saying this is stupid and why is he
talking about my childhood friends like
this i'm sorry i'm sorry
you